i know with my husband he's kind of a
sounding board i bounce ideas off of him
and jobs off of him quite a bit um when
it came to
this movie and other projects do you and
michael banter back and forth about
you know what might be good for you or
what might be good for him
yes all the time he does it with me i do
it with him
that's what i said like i think we're a
good team like he always is like
there for me or even like it's funny
i do auditions and i don't have nobody
to do the lines with me so he's my
my coach my my other actor like he does
it all for me so he helps me so much
mike is so passionate right like he's so
transparent like you will see
you know he can't hide right like you'll
see like
and that's so good i think he's a good
actor he has like a feelings
now let's talk about your movie fair
market value this is your first
english speaking role hey everybody this
is
gracias
kendo this is kendall everyone it was a
big opportunity for me
um yeah of course my english is not my
first language
do you see i'm compromising and i
promise i won't take your insulting
offer and ask you to kiss
my ass now i'm compromising
the spanish actress like you know you
feel like um
insecure about your english about your
accent about
what if people doesn't understand when i
speak uh
but i had a beautiful group of people
around me that they helped me
so much we loved the scene where the
kids are watching a horror movie don't
think your dad would really want you
watching a horror movie
sure you would why do i find that so
hard to believe
who in the family is most likely to
allow the kids to do something that they
shouldn't you or like you know what we
go back and forth
i'm more like don't worry he's not gonna
fail you know don't worry he can climb
and he's like no he's gonna fail like
he's yes
he's more uh like safe like secure
you know like he always wants to be safe
with the kids and i'm like don't worry
you know they can cross
they can do this they can climb